The times are changing far faster than
they ever were before and that requires
a new kind of thinking: elastic thinking.
Yeah, so I guess you would just come from
being like "well, this has been useful"
Could we survive without rulers, without
the state?
What is truth? Why do we believe the things we do?  Whom do we believe and why?
Reading about quantum physics has really helped me
understandmy queer identity.
Nude seems to me
weird shades of pink and multiple shades
of beige and in my humble opinion
mainstream fashion brands still make
women of colour feel invisible.
The more you're exposed to what other people think
the broader your own thinking will be.
There we go, that will do!
Cheers!